mais d'abord donc les gilets jaunes
retour sur un mouvement parti d'un
rond-point du nord de la france et qui a
fait vaciller la présidence d' emmanuel
macron avec hugo lemonnier
ils ne sont plus qu'une poignée réunis
samedi dernier là où tout a commencé
trois ans plus tard toujours la même
colère toujours les mêmes revendications
je veux vivre et ne pas survivre et
trois ans après
c'est toujours le même
le même résultat qu'en octobre 2018 le
président lançait dans une itinérance
mémorielle dans l'est et le nord de la
france est rattrapé par la montée d'un
mouvement de contestation avec un signe
de ralliement le gilet jaune
le gouvernement ne le sait pas encore
mais son projet de taxe sur les
carburants a réveillé une colère
profonde est déjà une figure se démarque
jacqueline moreau à l'origine d'une
vidéo visionnée plus de six millions de
fois sur facebook on vit pas tous en
ville moi je fais 25000 km par an donc
j'ai pas le choix que de prendre ma
voiture qu'elle pollue auquel ne pollue
pas 17 novembre 2018 des ronds points
aux champs elysées la france se pare de
jaune précaire mères isolées
travailleurs pauvres
le mouvement met en avant une frange de
la population
d'ordinaire mise à l'écart du débat
public mais nous on aime ou trop peu ou
trop riche pour lui on est les derniers
corps des parce que les premiers corps
disons d'où nous on n'a rien mais dès
les premiers actes de la mobilisation
les manifestations tournent à l'émeute
la répression policière fait de nombreux
blessés main arrachée manifestants
éborgné
[Musique]
pour éteindre l'incendié emmanuel macron
sort le carnet de chèques
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires primes exceptionnelles
annulation de la hausse de csg sur les
petites retraites en tout 17 milliards
d'euros mis sur la table et un mea culpa
du chef de l'état il a pu m'arriver de
vous donner le sentiment que ce n'était
pas mon souci que j'avais d'autres
priorités
je sais aussi qu'il m'est arrivé de
blessés certains d'entre vous par mes
propos c'est le début d'un exercice
inédit le grand débat national
dix mille réunions citoyennes organisées
à travers la france
finalement c'est un jour
mais cette vaste consultation est aussi
l'occasion pour emmanuel macron de
mettre en scène son dialogue avec les
citoyens et leurs élus la vraie
inégalité dans notre pays c'est qu'avec
le même talent la même motivation
là deux enfants français n'auront pas
les mêmes chances de réussir dans des
familles différentes ou dans des lieux
différents au terme du grand débat on
dénombre près de deux millions de
contribution avec au coeur des
revendications
la question fiscale notre pays a atteint
aujourd'hui une sorte de tolérance
fiscale 0 ne sais pas si on peut
l'appeler comme ça mais c'est souvent
comme ça qu'elle est exprimée nous
devons baisser et baisser plus vite les
impôts samedi après samedi le mouvement
des gilet jaune marque un net recul sans
jamais disparaître
des manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites au mouvement contre le pass
sanitaires le gilet jaune reste trois
ans plus tard comme un étendard de la
contestation
que reste-t-il des gilets jaunes on en
débat tout de suite et vous présente mes
invités michel wieviorka bonsoir
sociologue n'est publié où va la france
métamorphose ou d'échéance et aux
éditions rue de seine isabelle veyrat
masson bonsoir directrice de recherche
au cnrs directrice du laboratoire
communication et politique du cnrs
cédric zago bonsoir vous êtes directeur
de l'association des maires ruraux de
france avec nous en visioconférence yves
castéra quête artisans gilet jaune
bonsoir vous êtes membre de
l'association éveil citoyens qui
regroupe les gilets jaunes de la région
de de tarbes et puis l'accueil également
mathieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique à mes côtés comme tous les
lundis et mercredis peut-être la
question générale je vous propose à
chacun une réponse assez assez courte
parce qu'on va pouvoir détailler ensuite
qu'est ce qui reste de ce mouvement
trois ans après spontanément qu'est ce
qui vous vient michel wieviorka un
spasme un moment où la société se cabre
mouvement porté non pas par les plus
pauvres mais par des gens qui n'arrivent
pas à finir le mois qui sont dans des
régions désertifier une révolte sociale
une révolte sociale
horizontale incapable de passer à la
politique peut-être malheureusement mais
un moment de la plus haute importance un
moment important avec cette
revendication fiscale isabelle veyrat
masson c'est ce qui a frappé c'est ce
qu'a lancé le mouvement et finalement
c'est on va peut-être en s'en rendre
compte dans le débat c'est ce qui reste
encore aujourd'hui alors que le pouvoir
d'achat est encore la préoccupation
première des français enfin c'est un peu
le lendemain la coop 26 c'est quand même
un peu un paradoxe se dire ça parce que
c'est à la fois la question fiscale et
c'est aussi la question d'écologie
ceux ci avaient une chose dont on est
bien sûr c'est que les taxes carbone
sont efficaces en ce qui concerne la
question du climat est léger choses sont
d'abord sortis pour s'élever contre la
taxe carbone d'une certaine manière
c'est une sorte de symbole et gilet
jaune sévère à la fois une révolte front
des fonds du ce que l'impôt est toujours
quelque chose quand on n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent et qu'on gagne pas de l'argent
qui est insupportable et d'ailleurs
edouard philippe quand on pense qu'il
faudrait faire il parle d'un pot c'est
la réponse un peu de la droite est en
même temps un fondées parce que s'il ya
une chose qui est important aussi c'est
la question d'environnement et de la
transition écologique et du climat et là
les gilets jaunes n'ont pas choisi entre
on le sait entre la fin du monde est là
la fin de mois ils ont choisi la fin de
mois mais la fin dieu du monde inquiète
quand même c'est un examen aux mêmes
questions en quelques mots qu'est ce qui
reste pour vous de ce mouvement trois
ans après une absence de réponse aux
enjeux de la vie quotidienne de la part
de l'ex de la part de l'exécutif et pas
que de l'exécutif de tous les opérateurs
publics
département région et à une absence de
réponse aux sujets de la vie quotidienne
la situation sur l'accès aux soins sert
à empirer la situation économique vous
l'avez évoqué il ya toujours cette
perception que aujourd'hui sur la taxe
sur les produits et sur les carburants
il faut toujours se prendre sa voiture
pour se déplacer il n'y a pas de
solution de nouvelles alternatives à la
voiture individuelle ouais c'est des
sujets de la vie quotidienne et pour là
on est très loin du compte
répondra vraiment à votre question sur
qu'est ce qui reste moi je trouve que ce
qu'il reste vraiment c'est la menace
hier que en ce moment il est toujours
john se sent comme dans tous les débats
le sentiment qu'il y ait une menace si
les gilet jaune sont là on sait pas très
bien
et ça en ce moment avec la campagne
électorale ça je crois qu'il faut il
faut le rappeler d'accord avec cette
idée oui c'était ce que j'ai à répondre
c'était une crainte il reste à une
crainte de la part du point relais des
pouvoirs de passer à côté de quelque
chose d'avoir un mouvement parce que
c'est un moment que personne n'a vu
venir en tant que tel et puis c'est un
mouvement qu'on n'a pas su gérer d'une
certaine façon au sommet de l'état
puisque ça finit par se déliter après de
la grande au grand tour de force du
modèle macro mais tellement par le rail
à cette menace est donc cette crainte de
la part du pouvoir que ça se réveille
aux deux passés à côté d'un mouvement
similaire alors évidemment dans ce débat
aussi avoir un représentant alors c'est
difficile de dire un représentant des
jeunes puisque par essence ce mouvement
il était très pur était fort mais on
voit ceux qui sont encore sur les sur
les ronds-points castéra trois ans après
pourquoi vous vous êtes toujours
mobilisés finalement
alors d'abord jeu
il ya plusieurs questions dans votre
question
d'abord je ne représente pas le
mouvement des gilet jaune je suis
mandaté par la fédération d'associations
de gillet gens là il s'agit vous venir
parler ce soir
je pense qu'ils restent d'aborder ce qui
est d'aller trois depuis ses trois ans
du mouvement des gilet jaune j'ai
entendu certains propos qui m'ont kim
heurte un petit peu mais toute
bienveillance ce que vient par là c'est
que
nous rentrons d'un politique nous sommes
un politique le terme politique à ces
organisations de la cité or le mouvement
des gilet jaune pendant la première
année c'était mouvement ça a été des
citoyens un gilet jaune qui ont commis
le gilet jaune pour être visible
vis-à-vis de la société et des
institutions
et c'est la colère qui les a menés dans
la rue et la goutte de décence a fait
déborder le vase delà de la pauvreté et
de l'insupportable la deuxième année du
mouvement des gilet jaune ça a été la
mise en la mise en place de
l'association de structures de deux
collectifs de qg et c'est la troisième
année pour répondre aux questions que
vous ne posez pas mais sur lesquelles
certaines personnes déjà répondu c'est
que nous sommes en train de créer des
structures la fédération d'associations
de gilet jaune ces tissus d'une d'une
réflexion collective pour faire en sorte
de réseauter entre guillemets toutes les
associations il y en a à peu près deux
salles en france y compris avec la
guadeloupe nous travaillons beaucoup
avec la guadeloupe pour travailler sur
les projets du mouvement dit j'ai les
jeunes et notamment sur le triptyque
justice fiscale et sociale et climatique
nous pour répondre à madame je suis
désolé j'ai je n'ai pas son nom
nous raterons apolitique nous sommes en
politique bien évidemment puisque nous
avons demandé en tant que fédération de
gilet jaune nous avons demandé de
participer à l'emea la mission
d'information sur la participation
électorale c'est une c'est à
l'initiative de l'assemblée nationale et
cette mission d'information donne
naissance à une mise en place en ligne
d'une consultation sur l'abstention une
consultation citoyenne or nous en tant
que fédération d'associations de 6-2 2-6
légende nous avons toute légitimité à
travailler avec l'assemblée nationale
sur la question de l'abstention
on a quarante minutes de débat et vous
serez évidemment très présent et
régulièrement vous aurez la parole ne
vous inquiétez pas mais mais c'est très
intéressant ce que vous lever tout de
suite
michel wieviorka et isabelle masson pour
y répondre sur le la constitution
finalement de ce mouvement en force en
force politique le sentiment qu'on a eu
c'est que le mouvement des jeunes n'a
pas eut réussi à ceux à devenir une
force politique en tout cas un parti
politique au sens où on l'entend ça
c'est factuel mais ils veulent peser
certains d'entre eux veulent quand même
peu d'heures non seulement il n'a pas
réussi mais je ne sais pas s'il faut
dire qu'il n'a pas su ou qu'il n'a pas
voulu jouer dès qu'un leader avait une
certaine importance
en lui couper les ailes d'une manière ou
d'une autre et sans pendant un temps
mais la réaction je parle de
représentants je me suis repris dans la
dent voilà c'était peut-être pas
exactement le monde ont perçu comme des
représentants il n'y a pas de
représentant cette femme qui a poussé le
premier grand cri jacqueline gourault eu
la chance de discuter un jour avec elle
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait les pires
ennuis les pires menaces et c est que l
essayer de faire un peu de politique au
niveau local simplement justement parce
qu'on ne voulait pas qu'elle en fasse
plus c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que quand ce mouvement a
essayé de s'élever je dirai au dessus
c'est pas ira chic ce que dit la met au
dessus d'eux le coût de la vie le prix
de l'essence et ce genre de choses il a
voulu être plus institutionnel et l'a
mis en avant le thème du revenu ne pas
du revenu du mot fin du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et je ne dirais
pas que celle-là a beaucoup fait
progresser celle là peut être un peu
déporté vers la gauche car c'est plutôt
un thème si je peux dire à la mélenchon
qu'un thème
d'extrême droite et puis j'aurais
rappeler une chose parce que on ne le
dit pas avec assez de force ce soir ce
mouvement est né de questions de
mobilité automobile oui parce que non
seulement il est il s'est cru construit
vraiment sur la hausse des prix des
produits pétroliers mais avant tout le
pays en dehors de descendre de grandes
villes grandey avec la fameuse histoire
de la limitation de vitesse placé et
donc c'est un mouvement qui tire je
pense beaucoup de ça de son de son
énergie de son dynamisme à cette
question de la mobilité delà de la
diagonale du vide des déserts et cetera
et si je peux juste ajouter un dernier
mot c'est un mouvement et c'est une de
ses faiblesses qui n'est ni dans le
vieux monde ni dans le nouveau monde
c'est pas je défends des retraites le
manière plus ou moins corporatiste c'est
plutôt le vieux monde s'est pas non plus
vive l'écologie le mouvement des femmes
ce genre de de contestation ça c'est le
nouveau mot ils sont là pour dire enfin
ils étaient là pour dire avant tout nous
ne voulons pas être les laissés pour
compte faire les frais ou de tout ça
mais je ne crois pas que ce mouvement
s'installe quelques pas en arrière ou en
avant on va évidemment continuer d'en
débattre ce cet élément enquête ipsos
auprès steria pour france inter à
l'occasion de ce troisième anniversaire
une résurgence est elle possible la
réponse à son âge c'est oui à 81 2%
alors ça rejoint la problématique de la
mène à la transformation de la menace et
de la transformation en autre chose un
moment politique ou une autre forme
d'action isabelle veyrat masson est ce
que vous croyez que c'est très dur aux
résurgences aller les possibles de façon
nous sommes un peuple de révoltes et des
révolutions et je me souviens m'être
parmi vous journalistes pour essayer de
comprendre de quel type était ce moment
là on avait parlé du jacquerie on l'a
montré le caractère spontané populaire
et non organisée de la révolte on a
parlé de poujadisme parce que c'était
pas effectivement les milieux ouvriers
ou paysans qui était plutôt du côté du
marxisme et des mouvements de gauche
mais plutôt des petits commerçants ce
n'était pas des gens ça n'était pas la
misère qui descendait dans la rue
c'était dvd des gens intermédiaires ont
su aller chez les jaunes avaient plutôt
une jolie maison et de cécile était
révolté donc on a on a beaucoup réfléchi
sur ces sur la nature de ce mouvement et
on n'a pas trouvé mais c'est vrai que
nous avons pas mal d'exemples dans notre
histoire de mouvements populaires celui
là celui est assez inédit il est assez
inédit non seulement parce que ils
représentent des couches de la
population nouvelle également parce
qu'il ya des problèmes nouveaux les
problèmes de transports michel new york
elle le disait et aussi parce qu'il
s'est servi de mode de communication
nouveau également un c'est vrai on se
souvient de la mobilisation à travers
facebook de la capacité qui ont eu les
jaunes s'adresser à la population avec
d'autres moyens que traditionnel donc
des rivaux traditionnels comme nous
avons en osant avoir en france
régulièrement avec des modes
d'intervention de mobilisation nouveau
finalement il m'a frappé avec le recul
c'est quand même le caractère anarchiste
alors si c'est archi ce sont d'anciens
le refus du leader refus de
l'organisation là le rejet de l'état de
le rejet des institutions et les choses
de très anciens et que nous connaissons
bien dans notre histoire et qui est un
mouvement qui a eu sur l'importance en
france mais qui n'a jamais finalement eu
de débouché politique réelle parce que
justement il comme ontologiquement comme
dans sa nature propre du mouvement
quelque chose qui rejette qui refusent
l'organisation politique aspire à un
bout de réponse est ce que vous vous
sentez l'âme d'un anarchiste ça doit
vous faire réagir d'entendre ça alors
moi je trouve très incroyable que là je
trouve qu'il ya deux paradigmes qui
s'affrontent ce que j'entends c'est
essayer de placer le mouvement des jets
les jeunes dans un tiroir qui appartient
à votre paradigme recherche ne sommes
pas là dedans quand vous dites que nous
sommes dans l'impossibilité d'aller plus
loin d'avancer parce qu'on sait pas
parce qu'on peut pas parce qu'on nous
coupe les têtes chaque fois qu à une
personne qui émergent c'est pas tout à
fait ça c'est que les institutions le
problème c'est sur les institutions qui
nous empêche de faire ça je vous donne
un exemple un seul exemple on parle des
grands partis et des petits partis vous
savez que emmanuel kant quand on parle
du pouvoir d'achat on parle du gasoil on
parle d'écologie on n'a pas choisi fin
du monde versus fin du mois on n'a pas
fait le choix c'est pas vrai on
travaille sur les deux volets la
fédération d'associations de gilet jaune
a créé la coordination nationale du avec
tous les mouvements historiques du tout
les groupes historiques du mouvement et
nous travaillons sur toutes ces
constantes là sur toutes ces valeurs
écologiques démocratique fiscales
sociales sauf qu'on s'est rendu compte
en tirer les ficelles que quand on
touche et le maillot de l'as du pouvoir
d'achat ou de l'écologie revenaient
systématiquement aux maillons de la
démocratie or aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que depuis trois ans
quatre ans on est gouverné à coup de
d'état d'urgence sanitaire et de conseil
de défense le la population quels que
soient les sujets la population qui
appartient au mouvement des gilet jaune
puisque je suis là pour ça ouvre ce soir
la population n'est pas concertés encore
une fois on demande en réponse on répand
une prérogative de l'assemblée nationale
sur sur cette mission de consultation
sur la participation électorale est on
est on n'est pas entendu on ne peut pas
participer
je suis bien je comprends bien que
effectivement c'est une revendication et
qui n'est pas entendu ces examens sur la
résurgence que disait isabelle veyrat
masson cette crainte de l'exécutif
comment vous vous l'apercevez cette
possibilité parce que ce qu'on retient
c'est qu'ils renvoient le mouvement il
est quand même il est moins médiatique
on le voit on ne voit pas il magnifie
n'y a plus une manifestation tous les
samedis peut-être que ça fait pas voilà
le le miel des des chaînes d'infos et
des médias chaque week-end mais il ya
encore cette revendication elle est
toujours là aussi nous ce qu'on ressent
parce que les mères peuvent ressentir la
menace c'est pas de la résurgence d'un
mouvement c'est la menace c'est de
l'absence de réponse à ce qu'il ya
derrière puisque les gilet jaune on sait
ce que ça avec un mouvement c'est une
partie de la population nous que l'on
capte c'est peut-être une nouvelle forme
aujourd'hui c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous interrogez des maires sur leur
réalité de vie et d'animation de du
collectif qui est une communauté
citoyenne qui est un village ils nous
disent aujourd'hui les gens ne se
supportent plus entre eux dire que la
vraie menace aujourd'hui c'est de dire
il y a l'absent à l'absence de réponse
sur la mobilité sur la santé sur
l'emploi etc il ya une espèce de
saturation et que les élus captcha à
nous quand on ouvre les mairies le lui
descend 2018 bien avant les cahiers
citoyens de la nef et c'est bien avant
le lancement du grand débat c'est quoi
c'est de faire que la soupape faire
lever la soupape parce que c'est pas
léger léger c'est pas que les gilet
jaune et nous quand on ouvre les mairies
de ce fameux samedi c'est plein de gens
c'est ceux qui étaient devant leur télé
à regarder les jets les gens qui vivent
la même chose que ça c'est 22 millions
d'habitants dans ces territoires ce que
le mouvement des gilets jaunes
indépendamment de toute la
caractérisation politique que vous
essayez d'en décrire c'est d'abord une
géographie et donc
ils sont venus dire quoi les gens dont
36 sont venus ils soient habillés sont
apprêtés ils sont venus et nous l'avez
dit vous écrivez on n'y aura pas de
filtre et ils se sont exprimés en disant
j'existe et c'est cette question là en
fait et aujourd'hui quand nos mères nous
parle de cette réalité là ce matin
michel fournier se notre président sur
une autre sur une radio et expliquer
aujourd'hui le principal la principale
mission la mer c'est de faire cohabiter
les tensions et les tensions c'est la
résurgence de l'absence de réponse à la
question salariale à la question de la
laisser aux services etc alors ça c'est
vraiment une thématique importante parce
qu'il ya eu effectivement le grand débat
on va en parler puis a eu ses cahiers de
doléances ce citoyen 16 1337 cahier je
vous propose d'écouter le politologue
pascal perrineau qui était l'un des
garants du grand débat il était dans
l'émission y est on était depuis le
congrès des maires de france et il
parlait justement de ces cahiers de
doléances écoutons le énormément de
choses se sont dites dans ce grand débat
le gros problème est la grande limite
c'est une fois de plus un état central
qui reste sourd à ce qui s'est dit parce
que au fond j'ai essentiellement
d'ailleurs dans mon bureau des piles
entières de résumés de ces grands débats
qui s'en est véritablement servi quels
sont les administrations d'état quel est
le gouvernement quels sont les
ministères qui se sont emparés de cette
matière première phénoménal michel
wieviorka si on reprend déjà le grand
débat et ceux auxquels participaient
emmanuel macron parce qu'il ya eu aussi
beaucoup de débats citoyens organisés
dans dans de nombreuses mairies
notamment des mairies rural où il y
avait évidemment pas de grandes
personnalités politiques mais ce ceux
organisés en la présence des mânes le
maquereau est ce que vous aviez vous le
sentiment qu'elle gilet jaune n'était
pas justement l'idée du grand débat elle
est géniale il ya une crise je la
transforme en débat et quand même une
idée magnifique sauf que il faut faire
le débat avec les acteurs de la crise or
on n'a pas beaucoup vu les gilet jaune
dans ce grand débat est donc aux
remarques fait pascal perrineau qui
insiste quand même beaucoup sur le non
traitement de lait qui s'est dit durant
quelque chose de honteux
où en plus de ça ce débat n'a pas été
construit avec ce qui devait être au
coeur de les changes de la discussion
sinon marginalement rajouter une chose
parce que on fait comme si on oubliait
complètement un thème on n'a pas
prononcé le mot violence
la pérennité de ce mouvement durant des
semaines et des semaines si on ne
regarde pas ce qui s'est joué c'est très
compliqué d'ailleurs avec la violence
mais en tout cas ce qui est un signe de
faiblesse et pas de force mais en tout
cas le grand débat moi je suis d'accord
l'idée n'a pas été enfin le résultat
n'est pas à la hauteur de tout ce qui a
été dit
sur ce qu'on a vu dans le reportage tout
à l'heure
vous faire un débouché politique un
mouvement qui n'en avait pas et parce
que c'est un mouvement composite vous
l'avez dit parce que c'est un mouvement
de colère c'est très différent par
exemple des bonnets rouges vous souvenez
de ce mouvement retombe y signait déjà
contre une forme d'éco taxe avec les
portiques et que vous voulez à battre
igor dessous il voulait voir mais il
voulait abattre les portiques et terminé
d'ailleurs le projet a été retiré et ils
ont obtenu gain de cause là c'était très
compliqué de donner gain de cause au
mouvement des jeunes parce qu'ils
étaient composite parce que on a quand
même assister dans les débuts et dans
les manifestations en tous cas à une
tentative de récupération de l'extrême
gauche et de l'extrême droite il faut le
dire moi je ne pensais pas voir de mon
vivant ddd de militants d'extrême gauche
et des militants d'extrême droite allait
casser l'arc de triomphe ensemble
c'était quand même très très particulier
et puis par ailleurs qu est-ce qui a
émergé il ya eu le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui est venue
après mais qui a dit filion
difficilement mobilisateur pour ce pour
tout le monde et dans les premiers
instants c'était de s'en prendre aux
institutions il fallait marcher sur
l'elysée il fallait marcher vers
l'assemblée nationale vous souvenez de
ces images de coups de poing faire
reculer les forces de l'ordre c'est vrai
qu'on va revenir au chapitre des
violences parce que les policiers aussi
on joue un rôle mais c'était un
mouvement de colère et de protestation
qui était anti système qui voulait
renverser le système or personne ne
proposant une voie pour y aller personne
ne proposant que ce soit par les urnes
que ce soit même par la révolution
personne ne proposant une alliance ni
personne ne proposant un programme et b
ce mouvement et n'avait pas de débouché
politique était juste la fonction de
grand débat ça a été sans doute pas de
répondre à toutes les angoisses
existentielles et tous les problèmes du
quotidien déchets mais ça permet aux
gens de parler alors était-il gilet
jaune ou non ça permet aux gens qui se
posent la question existe en tout cas de
faire valoir qu'une certaine fonderie
des demandes de gilbert d'intervenir
dans l'espace public le débat c'était
aussi une réponse aux demandes et jaune
c'est pas simplement pour détourner
l'attention et gilet jaune voulez vous
l'avez dit exister intervenir espaces
publics rappeler leurs problèmes et le
grand débat a été une des manières de
répondre à cette demande là et puis il
ya eu quand même quelques réponses en
particulier vous l'avez dit la
convention européenne citoyenne c'est à
dire que le débat sur l'écologie
c'est une certaine manière de répondre à
cette attaque fondamentale et qui vous
des problèmes énormes qu'on n'a pas
encore résolu qui était une critique da
par des jets régionaux de la démocratie
représentative
comment est-ce que le gouvernement pour
répondre à cette demande la dire que
c'était une demande de disparition de
dissolution à partir du moment où les
gilet jaune et c'était au coeur de leurs
demandes font ça que j'ai parlé darche
et qu'ils étaient nous ne voulons pas de
représentant non seulement il n'y aura
pas de représentant de notre mouvement
il n'y aura pas de représentants
nationaux nous n'acceptons pas que
quelqu'un se déclare comme étant notre
représentant ça voulait dire quoi la
demande de sa vient de demander à et
rappelez-vous le riz qu'est ce que
c'était c'était le cas chaque fois qu'il
y avait une loi il y avait une
nomination qu'il y avait un ministre il
fallait leur redemander au peuple son
aval le flux vendeur mais fermement leur
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'était quelque chose qui est qui niait
la base démocratie donc le gouvernement
nous fait pas évidemment répondre à
cette demande là ce qu'il a fait c'est
de la remettre en débat pour y réfléchir
et puis sur une certain nombre de
demandes s'est pour une fois il ya eu
aussi une sorte de référendum
d'initiative populaire
quand on dirait jamais lloret mais c'est
d'abord je voudrais quand même revenir
sur ces grands débats encore une fois
ils ont été il y en avait beaucoup
organisé dans énormément de petites ça a
quand même permis une parole un peu plus
apaisé on a parlé de la violence un prêt
mais dans ce cadre là mais ça aura près
on peut dire qu'il ya pas eu de réponse
mais la parole s'est exprimé mais c'est
là ou non ainsi statut c'est que le
maire falla la commune a joué ce rôle de
médiation mais y compris d'apaisement
c'est sans être dans une logique
politicienne nous irons va rendre
service aux actes à nous c'était de voir
qu'il y avait des gens qui part à
quitter le village est allé sur le rond
point à 5 ou 10 bandes de de leur
domicile et puis il ya tous ceux qui n'y
allez pas parce qu'ils se
reconnaissaient pas mais qui vivent les
mêmes choses nous symboliquement le 14
décembre janvier 2019 à la clôture une
séquence sur les cahiers de propre de
doléances et de propositions est-ce que
c'est pas qu'un mouvement de
contestation c'est aussi un mouvement de
propositions symboliquement qu'est-ce
qu'on remet au président la république
on lui remet une clé avec dedans 100%
s'il n'y a pas de traitement c'est un
comble on remet les choses brut et
qu'est ce qu'on voit de danse ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la santé la
mobilité tous des sujets vie quotidienne
sur lequel même s'il ya eu des milliards
bon c'est toujours un politique c'est
faire mais là on a vu comment les maires
finalement serait impose on sait les
difficultés de cet exécutif vous avec
les corps intermédiaires seraient impose
comme un filtre et le présent la
république dit à vanik berberian michel
fournier quand il les reçoit le 14
janvier et lui dit vous m'avez donné
l'idée du grand débat parce que il ya
cette idée d'apaisement et que
finalement même si derrière on sait que
même même sur le le spectre simplement
des élus qui sont dans un paquebot
hautement en france encore complètement
sans importance avec cinq cent mille
personnes
le 25 avril 2019 sur les questions des
élus il dit j'ai parcouru la france j'ai
rencontré effectivement il savait
comment ils organisaient des débats il
nous appelait en disant est ce que tu
veux vous pouvez nous mettre les
préfectures nous appeler pour dire qui
est ce que vous pouvez mettre et c'était
un bon et il dit j'ai compris que ces
gens là étaient essentiels à la vie
locale et je le demande un statut de
l'élu digne de ce nom est-ce que
promesses qu'il ne tiendra pas parce que
dans la langue et je mourrai proximité
derrière ça ne sort pas et puis si on
reprend autres autres éléments de
l'enquète ipsos auprès steria pour inter
de france inter
réponse à la question qu'on se posait
mâcon at il répondu au gilet jaune c'est
assez massif le nom l'emportent à
74% on va passer à la à la thématique de
la violence michel wieviorka et avant ça
je voudrais entendre un autre gilet
jaune je vais vous redonner la parole
tout à l'heure à yves castéra ne vous
inquiétez pas mais un autre gilet jaune
qui est sûre sur le rond-point dont on
parlait dans notre reportage en point
dans le nord de la france il s'appelle
gilbert rigal il est retraité et ce qui
m'intéresse et qui fait le lien entre
les samedis des gilets jaunes et les
manifestations récentes anti-vaccins
écouter ou manger les jeunes en lui-même
ne va pas renverser
la table enfin le système à vis tout
seul mais il a enclenché quelque chose
et ce qui s'est passé cet été par
exemple toutes ces manifestations
complètement improbable inattendue nous
on se dit c'est quand même un peu la
suite de ce qu'on a fait alors qu'est ce
que vous faites le lien tient entre
entre les deux mouvements le mouvement
des jeunes est une forme de continuation
avec les manifs anti val je ne dirai que
bien sûr il ya du chevauchement et mais
je pense que l'asnl est en mouvement
anti jax anti passe oui les antilles
macron c'est la nature de ce mouvement
me semble être très différente de celle
du mouvement des gilets jaunes le
mouvement des gilets jaunes on vient de
le redire c'est un mouvement qui met en
avant des thèmes sociaux avant tout est
un peu institutionnels pour le dire
comme ça le mouvement antivaccin c'est
un mouvement qui touche à tout à fait
autre chose c'est-à-dire le vaccin la
science la médecine et le passé s'est
réunie la détestation du présent alors
oui mon fils bien sûr il ya eu un côté
requis macron
confirmé d'ailleurs d'ailleurs jamais
les anti vaccins n'ont mobilisé avec la
même alors je vais revenir la question
de la violence comment vous l'analysez
cette violence parce que je vous donnais
mon point de vue de deux journalistes
s'étaient c'était une matière médiatique
parfaite pardon mais voilà c'est vrai
qu'elle a aussi fait voilà le
l'événement l'actualité des week-ends
c'est la télévision c'est aussi un
spectacle et des images de violence
c'est un spectacle c'est horrible à dire
mais c'est une réalité alors il faut
dire des choses qui sont assez complexes
premièrement mathieu gratton de la l'a
rappelé il ya un instant il ya eu de la
violence d'extrême d'ultra droite se
diraient même pas extrêmement 2010 outre
à droite et de la violence du genre
black box c'est à dire plutôt ultra
gauche il a démarré plutôt à droite ou
l'extrême droite alors disons arrivé en
tant que disons que le côté ultra droite
me semble t'il s'est considérablement
affaiblie dans les viols ce problème
deuxièmement il ya au départ au départ
une assez grande distance entre les
acteurs de la violence donc les ultras
d'un borne haute et le mouvement qui
n'est pas un mouvement violent non moi
je ne dirai jamais que les gilet jaune
au départ son violent donc mais
évidemment il ya une sorte de deux
pactes non dits qui profite aux deux les
les acteurs de la violence ont besoin de
ces grosses manifestations pour pouvoir
s'exprimer et les manifestants grâce à
la violence obtienne ce que vous venez
de rappeler c'est à dire une grande
visibilité médiatique tous les samedis
après midi bon moi je fais partie de ces
gens moi j'ai qui ont passé un temps
énorme sur tous les plateaux de télé
parce qu on me sollicitait sur ces
enjeux c'était très intéressant
mais il arrive un moment où premièrement
des gilets jaunes sont pris en situation
dans une charge policière féroce une des
brutalités policières que celle et des
rêves deviennent violents eux mais
premièrement il arrive aussi à un moment
où un certain nombre de personnes côté
gilet jaune décide de venir participer à
l'action il y aura donc les choses
deviennent plus compliquées mais une
chose est claire c'est que plus on parle
de la violence et de rien d'autre de
beaucoup à d'autres jeunes et plus ça
veut dire que ce mouvement est en train
de retomber ce qui finalement son
aboutissement ils castéra votre réaction
7 cette analyse est peut-être aussi
comment vous vous avez vécu cette
violence du mouvement de l'intérieur
alors il ya un sujet qui m'est passé
sous le nez rapidement si vous permettez
le grand débat dans le débat je voudrais
qu'on avance excusez moi
qui mène les débats je sais vous allez
dire c'est encore les parisiens qui y
est je voudrais vraiment qu'on avance
nous reste qu est très peu de temps et
donc je voudrais que vous entendre sur
cette question de la violence et on
l'avait résumé mouvement à ça on est
bien d'accord c'est bien donc je suis
bien d'accord la violence quant au fait
un petit peu l'analyse de cette violence
là on est bien d'accord que sept jeux il
ya eu il ya eu des actes de violence de
la part de certains individus et des
actes de violence de la part du
gouvernement
quand un gouvernement grec est
illégitime parce qu'il eut avec moins de
28 % aux dernières élections mais
évidemment comme et la police en
interface entre les décisions d'un
gouvernement et la population pour
qu'ils obligent à ces décisions là si on
prenait en compte le vote
vème république ça il ya toujours eu un
candidat du premier tour qui fait 28 30
% au mieux et qui ont infligé ces
essais n'ont fonctionné mais sont
illégitimes auront été légitime et bien
et bien mais la question du mouvement du
gilet jaune elle est là et il faut
vraiment écouté le mouvement c'est que
le principe démocratique aujourd'hui
n'est pas respectée on est gouverné par
un par un par un président de la
république dont je respecte la fonction
on est gouverné par quelqu'un qui sur le
plan de la représentativité électorale
est illégitime que c'est tout simple 66
% de 66 % d'abstention aux dernières
élections régionales
66%
comment comment vous viennent avec ça et
lyon mais la police en mai la police en
interface en mai les policiers à
l'interface et puis là ça va générer de
la violence de la part de certains
individus qui n'attendent que ça et on
tue nos mouvements à travers sa voix là
même ce qu'on veut pour réagir sur le
sur le plateau georges jour bien avant
une seconde matthieu croissandeau vous
dit gdba savoir si on pousse or le score
du premier tour du président pour savoir
s'il est légitime pour appliquer quand
même eu des législatives derrière qui
ont doté ce président d'une majorité
très large au parlement qui lui a permis
de conduire sa politique de gérer le
fonctionnement de nos institutions on
peut la remettre en cause mais je viens
c'est le fonctionnement des institutions
de notre démocratie moi je pense que le
mouvement des légions qui s'est abîmé
dans la violence et je ne suis pas
persuadé que ce soit juste une question
de quelques individus parce qu'on a vu
effectivement des gens qui n'étaient pas
forcément mû par la violence au début
deux venir violent et puis il ya eu des
symboles qui ont été pris d'assaut on
pense que je repense à la préfecture du
puy en velay gens pensent à a des choses
à paris demandé aux commerçants qui sont
fait casser les vitrines tous les
samedis que ce soit à paris ou à
bordeaux dans les villes voient ou dans
d'autres villes s'ils n'ont pas vécu de
l'intérieur cette violence qui n'était
pas juste le fait de quelques casseurs
s'étaient estienne violence et de
partager rappelez-vous les policiers
quand ils fouillaient les manifestants
il trouvait chez des bons pères de
famille entre guillemets ou des bonnes
mères de famille des gourdins des
matraques des boules de pétanque donc
c'était ce mouvement était hélas la
violence était inhérente à ce mouvement
sans doute parce que la colère était
forte et que la violence n'était que
l'écho de la colère mais on peut pas
dissocier dissocier de et ce n'était pas
à mes yeux juste la sphère de quelques
groupuscules après évidemment les forces
de l'ordre n'ont pas su réprimer ce
mouvement elles n'ont pas su le faire
donc elles l'ont fait dans une violence
extraordinaire elle aussi ce qui fait
que les deux se sont auto alimenté mais
voilà c'est pas la mesure de cas pas
juste alors
puisqu'on n'a pas dit depuis le début et
qui fait la force quand même des gilet
jaune c'est l'incroyable soutien de la
population mesurer à travers les
sondages rappelez vous pendant tout le
mouvement ça va durer un an deux ans de
plus de 70% des français interrogés
soutiennent mouvements légers les jours
et ça ça donne au gilet jaune une force
et même aux journalistes une légitimité
pour donner la parole à ce mouvement il
est très important alors certains comme
roland cayrol 10 de toute façon les
mouvements pour la fin du mois sont
toujours populaires c'est vrai mais on
pourrait être étonné que ce mouvement
populaire dans le sens très très
largement populaire va chercher du côté
de la violence pour s'installer donc il
ya là mon sens l'outil une sorte de de
contradictions mais cette contradiction
s'explique également par ce par notre
système médiatique et il est clair que
la violence il va être utilisé pour
maintenir l'intérêt des médias des
politiques sur un mouvement qui n'a pas
un énorme
d'énormes présentation nous reste moins
d'une minute vrai que entendre votre mot
de conclusion ces examens justement
c'est intéressant dans le triptyque
violence
colère
et soutient le fait de venir à paris
c'est l'agrégation de la colère de la
province qui vient rencontrer l'univers
médiatique en écho parce que y'a pas
d'écouté vous avez très bien interprété
ça c'est bien une question d'agrégation
de colère de non-dits d'accumulation de
frustration on lire sur toute une série
de sujets et sur lequel effectivement un
moment donné il ya les violences de part
et d'autre on le sait mais séoul avait
dit aussi tout à l'heure c'est parce que
il ya une captation médiatique qui fait
qu' il ya un écho et c'est là où c'est
intéressant au sens où c'est dangereux
puisque ça permet à tout le monde au
gilet jaune comme à l'exécutif de ne pas
traiter le sujet au fond qui est
d'apporter des réponses très pragmatique
et aujourd'hui je peux vous garantir sur
tous ces sujets là on a vu passer des
éléments qui dans les éléments de
langage de discours nous on a obtenu un
agenda rural mélange annales c'est des
propos c'est pas des mesures est
aujourd'hui dans la haie et on voit bien
qu'on retourne depuis quelques semaines
sur la question du la tarification de
l'essence et moi je suis toujours ultra
dépendante du déplacement en voiture
alors qu'à paris je peux avoir 7 ou 8
moyens de transport alternatifs
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de d'être
intervenu dans l'émission michel
wieviorka je rappelle le titre de votre
livre où va la france métamorphose ou
des séances est publié aux éditions rue
de seine dans un